so you must remind yourself throughout
this ordeal of the good news there's no
question that our self distancing is
flattening the curve so the accumulation
of cases are spread out over time now
you're still gonna hear about the
growing number of infections but as that
occurs we should see the fatality number
go down but on the drug front there's
also promising news there knock on
sanitised wood researchers are reporting
on a combination of anti malarial meds
and antibiotics which were prescribed to
kovat patients and saw a significant
reduction in the viral load in them
meanwhile and a godel evidence straight
from patients mouths are attesting to
its success here's actor Daniel Dae Kim
who got the virus and then got the drugs
and here's what I consider to be the
secret weapon hydroxychloroquine yes
this is the drug that the president
mentioned the other day it is also the
drug that dr. Anthony Falchi cautioned
us about he said that evidence that the
drug was promising is anecdotal and that
is correct it means it was a study and
it's only based on personal accounts
well add my name to those personal
accounts because I am feeling better
that's good news for him how did the
media respond to all this well because
Trump had touted the drug on Twitter
what he expect MSN published a Bloomberg
news piece with the headline virus drug
touted by Trump can kill in just two
grams neglecting to point out that two
grams of a lot of things can kill you
trust me once again in the media who
love to tout their faith in science
flunk remedial math screw them back to
the good news if we can treat people and
reduce mortality even more that not only
can we save lives we can also save our
economy so yeah it might get scary but
hopefully the good news should soon
overtake the bad so first we had to
divide now fingers crossed we will
conquer so hey Dana I'm gonna ask you a
nerdy question okay oh it's so weird
you're not next to me it's very strange
alright um so you miss me yes I miss you
I'm alone except for Jesse's above me as
usual there's a net there's a we need
these yet we need these clinical trials
so we can tell if people just aren't
getting
on their own because a lot of people do
get better on their own and you have to
compare groups placebos with the group
that got the drug but then that poses an
ethical question because if this drug is
working do you want to be in the placebo
group I don't know say it was a nerdy
question that is a nerdy question and a
good one and thankfully there are
doctors that are working on this though
I would I'm hopeful but if this works
that we have the we know that the drug
can be made if it works I mean great and
I'll be patient and wait for people but
I do want to mention one thing Greg
talked to a friend of mine this weekend
who was a doctor has many patients that
called him over the weekend these are
pretty wealthy people demanding that
they be given this drug right so that
they could have it in their bathroom
cabinet just in case they maybe get cove
in 19 and they want to take care of
themselves first of all you're asking
your doctor to do something that's
unethical and second you are preventing
someone who might be really needed who
could get better from it from having it
and that of course then you could have a
supply and demand problem with the cost
so let's Pete let's hope that this works
but everybody if you are wealthy and you
think you want to stop by all this stuff
knock it off yeah it's it's that
inclination that I got the money I'll
just throw money at it and I'll be safe
you know um
Dagan you see if out she was cautious
about this and Trump is optimistic and I
always feel like it's the two sides of
the same coin and that bouchy has to be
the cautious voice and Trump has to be
the cheerleader but they're kind of
going in the same direction I think a
promising one no they are going in the
same direction there's so many other
promising therapies that are under
development we've talked about Regeneron
it has a monoclonal antibody drug it
developed a drug for Ebola it's got a
product in the works it could be out
already by this summer some ideas being
thrown out or these trials that you
should have multiple therapies in the
same large trial and even scale-up
manufacturing before we're sure they
work so for all the people who've spent
years vilifying biotechnology and
pharmaceutical companies they will save
the day and save the economy and we
be thankful we live in this country with
such a healthy drug development regimen
you know the good news I think one is
that all of the dire predictions that
they've been we've been hearing about
don't factor in the human creativity and
the human innovation that come out of
these companies and come out of
individuals just by just by self
distancing you being far away from me is
saving lives but it could be yeah but I
must say you know I I had just am
delighted that we see this kind of
potential for innovation I think it's
what really is going to you know be
miraculous I just think we have so many
smart people so many committed people
trying to come up with answers I mean
you know it's difficult to take on a
virus like if they give you Tamiflu Greg
you have to take it within the first few
hours of the symptoms so if you get
something now and then you have to give
it to people it's you know there's so
much to be determined what does worry me
is when I see the president
I thought we'd it out recently we don't
want the cure to be worse than the
illness or the problem and there were
reports and papers that he's getting
tired of all the medical experts you
know saying we need the social
distancing we can't just have everybody
rushed back because he's right in
thinking well but what about the economy
how far do we go with this yep before at
the risk of having our economy shut down
but I do think at this juncture I hope
the president even as you described it
as cheerleading I hope he would
understand that you got to listen to
doctor foul Chi to the Surgeon General
Durham Adams and others who are experts
in the field at this moment because I
think this is at right now at this
moment I would say a medical crisis all
right Jesse what are your thoughts on
this are you optimistic I'm optimistic
and I'm also realistic this country was
hopeful after Pearl Harbor after 9/11
after the Great Recession we can still
be hopeful now during the pandemic
there's nothing wrong with that and
everybody assesses risk differently
whether it's experimental drugs or
social distancing that doesn't make
people that are optimistic bad people
not
everything has to be a doomsday scenario
and we're seeing positive signs like
Apple for instance is donating a million
masks we've mobilized the National Guard
to build mass units they're sending a
navy ship that has a hospital inside of
it to New York Harbor next week
am I saying everything's perfect
absolutely not we need to ramp up the
defense production act to get these
masks these ventilators and Hospital
products out there as soon as possible
we need more testing desperately in this
country perhaps we issue war bonds so
the consumer can be more confident but
looking back afterwards because this is
going to be over we're gonna see
ourselves in a whole new way we got to
cook our own food spend time with loved
ones maybe explore different things that
we hadn't really thought about and we're
gonna come out of this okay what did you
explore yeah that's a personal question
that I felt we are gonna come out of
this okay I think you're right all right